here walking to this video I'm playing
the Blitz kick out from the Netherlands
I'm playing if he's playing he doesn't
play nope so come on play move yeah my
raging has suffered quite a bit this
code didn't help below two down three
hundred dumb does not happen solve yep
do we get a game yeah the main problem
is that you oh no is playing you often
click on this button to start a game and
then you're distracted and the game
starts while you're alone in the kitchen
fixing yourself something up in the
bathroom happened to be lots of times
okay we've got a London system and I'm
playing the system with c5 you should be
six usually am quite um quite a decent
setup let's see you to take him under
develop yeah hmm interesting
yeah interesting I means that i can play
five now completely opening up the
position if I maybe take with the night
actually you know gaining gaining some
well some moves it takes a 5d fire fist
God Bishop e3 zone then Quincy six is a
double attack Bishop see find one on g2
he has not castled this is the important
point if he would have capsuled no
problem at all but now g2 and c4 is
hanging what I don't see me really
Bishop c1r a bishop f1 is just plain
terrible okay so he wants to make a
sacrifice out of it I guess castling
wrong so I'll win a temple first on the
bishop and then take it too I guess or
is there batteries look the eight Queen
f1's also plain plain terrible looking
maybe it's better than then grabbing
material no 95 may yeah 95 been tending
to sacrifice on c3 yeah well okay I'm
not going to spend any time on that this
this really should work if not
something's terribly terribly off check
check okay let's see
mmm chance maybe not not completely
clear cut yeah there's no fairness in
this game okay look d to ya Quincy one
this is Sir still playable for some
reason I only have two pawns
look the two ladders Quincy one they
don't really want to trade and take on
have to yeah I don't know I've got III
maybe this is this is working now it's
the some other idea i can i can give the
check of course queen d for disruptive
one this is not helpful at all yeah
maybe anyway taking taking on t1 and
then checking on f2 this could be an
idea the opponent's is quite dangerous
he's got one check here but that said
the queen is covering f7 yeah that's of
course far too little for the position
that i had but ok let's see what this
position offers yeah I should have
thought a big part of taking on c3
playing this too quickly he's still and
not in an A and in great shape or or
anything but I probably had something
better I'm going to take as many points
as possible you can give a check and
another check I thought to go here
taking an eye on f7 I have have queen of
one now I can we can give the check on
e3 g5 is not especially great yeah well
measure maybe I can do that could be too
risky my king is shaky but I really
don't want to draw want to try to fight
him yeah I can give two checks grab
chocolate the pawn
now this looks this isn't this nice now
check good for four pawns green on this
check-check
I'd like to cover d7 by giving you a
trick don't don't see it maybe something
like that one minutes 11
maybe you can just play king before
activating threatening Bishop b5 know
try and try to oh this should help
really wait wait wait wait h5 is going
to play Bishop g5 anyway
you probably managed to draw this
maybe not time works in playing some
strange museum check white yeah yeah I
played the some be tempered weird white
sugar shouldn't lose i think around here
with our proper play lost he lost lots
of time with some moves yeah white
should lose i think it's a it's just a
drawn but around here it gets tricky
there's no reason to play king f3 really
nor the computer is giving me a big
advantage Bishop d7 that says is it
wrong yeah of course why does the White
can lose the game I don't don't I don't
run any big risk myself yeah I'd like to
I'd like to check the position here
again here I shouldn't take on oil and
c3 I was just dashing this out and this
is complete complete nonsense I should
play a five a form with the with
excellent position yeah 93 is just
complete crap check
yeah this is Jack this is better in
comparison check check yeah here i have
i can i can play here to try to force it
all if it goes to a one does look f2 and
now i'm in control yeah yeah i should
just play a five round here it's just
murky alright thanks for watching